you know the man the fbi calls the most  prolific serial killer in u.s history  died yesterday in california  eighty-year-old samuel little was  serving three consecutive sentences  of life without parole he confessed to  murdering 93 people  that's more than ted bundy and jeffrey  dahmer combined little prayed mostly on  vulnerable women  including drug addicts and sex workers  across 19 states  from california to florida he said his  killing spree began on new year's eve  1970.  that was 50 years ago today little's  confessions helped authorities solve  dozens of cold cases  not all of his victims have been  identified though officials have not yet  said  what caused little's death